selon le rapport 2020 sur les risques
globaux du forum économique les
principaux risques à court et à long
terme sont liés à l'environnement
le pdg du fonds d'investissements le
plus important de la planète blackrock a
expliqué à davos aujourd'hui le choix de
son entreprise de mettre en oeuvre un
virage vert dans ses investissements
la société américaine a annoncé la
semaine dernière que le risque
climatique sera dorénavant un critère
prioritaire dans ses orientations
rosalie van deth et experte en finance
durable on les retrouve à toronto madame
vendait de bonsoir morcenx et fignon
quand on parle de blackrock c'est le
plus gros gestionnaire de portefeuille
de la planète terre qui prends cet
engagement qui est important quel est le
signal quel est l'impact de cette prise
de position avait c'est un signal énorme
en fait parce que la lettre étant donné
la taille de blackrock la lettre est
envoyée aux pdg des différentes
entreprises dans lesquelles blackrock
détient des positions et elles se
comptent par milliers l'enjeu de taille
parce que les changements climatiques
appelle à des actions concrètes sur le
terrain est ce que blackrock vient il
dire c'est que c'est devenu une
composante essentielle de l'évaluation
du risque et donc de la valeur des
titres blackhwaks n'est pas le premier à
le faire puisqu'il y avait déjà une
myriade d'investisseurs institutionnels
qui le faisait plus près de nous et de
la caisse de dépôt et placement du
québec et une foule d'autres acteurs
sauf que quand bhl à quoi vient faire
une opération de communication aussi et
en silence un signal aux émetteurs aux
entreprises dans le fond pour dire
attention il ya des décisions qui vont
se prendre dans les prochaines années et
vous devez être au rendez vous à tout le
moins avec l'information et les actions
oui parce qu a pas si longtemps les
investisseurs voyaient se passer si on
avait un intérêt personnel pour les
questions environnementales on s'y
intéressaient mais les investisseurs ne
se souciait guère matic
il ya une coalition avec trois axiaux en
nombre de places qui interpelle
directement les cent plus gros émetteurs
de gaz à effet de serre les entreprises
qui sont cotées en bourse pour les
influencer
mais les actions qui sont nécessaires
sont immenses donc tous toutes
interventions bienvenues et le fait que
ce soit black rock avec le nom l'aurochs
l'entreprise possède le pouvoir
d'influencer sa devient un point
tournant qui s'ajoute à la longue ni
d'intervention qui avait eu lieu je
dirais peut-être depuis 2015 quand on
regarde où est le conseil la stabilité
financière
sous le leadership de mme arkani avaient
formé un comité de travail pour se
pencher justement sur l'information
financière liée au changement climatique
et les recommandations qu'ils ont fourni
au g20 et en 2017 allait dans le sens
d'une meilleure divulgation et c'est
intéressant parce que mark carney va
devenir l'envoyé spécial de l'onu sur le
climat il va quitter l'as dans les
prochaines semaines la banque
d'angleterre et je me rappelle qu'au
mois de septembre me disais si les
entreprises ne vise pas être carboneutre
elles se feront sanctionné par les
investisseurs elles doivent agir et
aujourd'hui même le rapport 2020 du
forum économique sur les grands risques
mondiaux place toutes les priorités
finalement tous les grands risques
c'est des risques environnementaux exact
les risques avec les plus grandes
probabilités les c'est énorme en fait
escale blackhwaks vient me dire dans sa
lettre c'est que ils s'attendent à ce
qu'il ya une réallocation massive des
capitaux alors on sait qu'on est dans
une ère de transition il faudra que nos
économies s'en aille vers des économies
à faible intensité en carbone et
blackrock dit il va se passer fort
probablement une réallocation massive
d'investissement vers des solutions à
faible intensité en carbone par des
entreprises qui s'inscrivent dans cette
logique là autrement dit ça veut pas
dire que elles vont tout passé au
travers il y aura probablement des
gagnants et des perdants et les
investisseurs de ce monde et chercha à
miser sur les gagnants et on retour
quel est l'effet où le poids des
déclarations du président entre hommes
face à cela
dans les milieux financiers que moi je
fréquente dans le milieu de la finance
durable
il ya eu aux états unis au moment de
l'élection de monsieur chrome qui par la
suite les annonces qui le plus fort par
rapport aux changements climatiques une
recrudescence de la vivacité des
interventions une recrudescence de la
collaboration des investisseurs aux
états unis il ya des gros investisseurs
décors originaux retraite étatique des
contrôleurs au niveau étatique qui
s'activent dans les milieux financiers
pour combattre les effets des
changements climatiques notamment que
les fournit exactement la coalition dont
j'ai fait mention à l'acclamer traction
los angeles coldplay était l'un des
fondateurs l'un des cofondateurs et ça
se passe aussi aux états unis bien sûr
le leadership en ce moment en matière de
finance durable est en train d'être pris
par l'europe
et parce que en europe l'action est
coordonnée par l'union eurpéenne et on
s'envoie de plus en plus vers des
mesures législatives à cet endroit la
chose qu'on voit pas nécessairement aux
états unis le petit investisseur
individuel c'est quoi son pouvoir reste
que les changements climatiques menacent
son portefeuille falémé changement
climatique menace tout le monde alors
cessé je pense que il faut pas se
leurrer nous nos portefeuilles à nous
pourrons pas y échapper nécessairement
donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est
s'attarder à ces questions là et prendre
les devants poser des questions par
rapport à la gestion de nos propres
actifs parce qu'il ya des solutions il y
a des options et les conseillers et
planificateurs financiers sont à même de
faire la différence ou à tout le moins
ne serait-ce que de leur poser la
question sa valeur comment ça va les
inciter à commencer le travail
rosalie van deth vous êtes expert en
finance durable merci pour ces
explications ce soir merci à vous